本来就是欠那么多债，
信用都烂包了，
还惦记着买房子，
就跟那个电视剧里似的，
自己手上你分没有，
非得问大姑姐借100万买房子谁还呢？
到最后不是还指着你吗？
你掺和们干什么呢？
我今天想向您咨询关于怎么处理跟原生家庭的关系，
还有个人成长婚恋这方面的问题哦。
我是01年的本科毕业，
这两年做短视频带货，
平均年收入在60万左右。
我哥嫂前几年和家里比较亲的亲戚做生意失败了，
欠了其他亲戚朋友的钱，
还有银行的贷款，
因为还不上，
都上征信黑名单了。
有两个侄子都在读小学，
之前他拿我爸妈名下的房产也做了35万的贷款，
是我还掉了，
最早他们的房子也被封了，
这两年他们都在租房住，
现在他们想买房子，
可能因为小孩这两年要上初中，
还有就是租房带着孩子确实不方便，
他们想买40万左右的二手房，
我出首付，
他们自己还贷款，
我之前说我支持20万，
他们后面说我赚钱不容易，
压力也大，
但我出十万首付也还没买，
就准备这一两年先看，
但是年底了，
各种那种亲戚朋友会来催债吧，
我妈跟我说的是，
如果实在不行，
我就出个一两万还一下，
跟为我刚嫂说明，
以后这种还款啊，
欠债就从这20万买房子的钱以后我就跟我妈说了，
我说。
这次我就要扣我哥嫂他们30多岁了，
初中文化，
没有劲能。
这两年我嫂子因为平时要照顾小孩，
一个月工资也就1000左右，
我哥就打点零工那种，
估计也没有多少，
主要是这几年经历过这些打击，
两个人都没有什么心气了一样，
感觉也很难再起来。
因为我妈妈平时要帮我做事嘛，
所去给他带人，
但是会给全家人做饭，
找个下班来打包饭菜就可以。
平时逢年过节我会给两个小孩红包，
加起来也有大几千，
开学那个托管班也是我在付这个钱，
我以后也会给抽回了。
刚刚那20万，
我是准备直接跟哥嫂说，
我就支持你们这20万，
不管你们是买房还是看什么，
其他的多了就没用，
想要过更好的生活就得靠你们自己了。
这两年我赚的钱也都花在你们身上了，
我自己的工作也不稳定，
但我妈妈年纪也大了，
也没有存款，
特别是我爸身体还不是很好，
我也要攒点钱，
我问你一个问题吧，
你一年能挣60万，
这个事情你们全家人知道吗？
我哥嫂可能不一定清楚，
但是我妈妈知道，
因为我刚毕业一年多，
我可能之前比较单纯，
前一年比如说一个月赚多少，
多的少的，
我都会跟我妈妈说，
今天挂完电话就跟你妈说单位出现了状况，
你这个是自己当老板，
还是别人给你发工资，
自己一个人做自媒体，
短视频发多少，
那你今天挂完电话了之后，
今天吃饭的时候就。
无意间向你妈提起今年短视频带货哀鸿遍野，
今年短视频带货实在太难做了，
很多大主播都付不了那个本钱，
其都得亏钱，
就是让你爸妈觉得你来钱也不容易，
你一年就挣个五万六万的，
是的，
但是他们大概知道，
因为他知道我一般能赚多少钱，
但是我今年有意说了啊，
我说我的客单价也低，
就2%，
3%，
5%的佣金，
也就几毛钱一块钱，
但他们会看我的那个，
不知道他们在哪里学的，
会看我的，
你有头牛啊，
你有成本啊，
是的，
要说的更加干啥对不对，
对，
尤其是你是一个女的啊，
真的，
现在很多当爹当妈的发现女儿能挣钱了，
恨不得得一直羊上薅羊毛薅你，
是的，
我说我不要纠结，
我就想说，
哎，
要不要直接跟他们说，
你不要说我就给你20万，
怎么怎么地的，
你必须要让他们知道，
釜底抽薪，
让他们知道你没挣钱，
你钱亏了，
投资亏了，
你没有钱，
他不是说我就上来，
就说我只给你们20万啊，
你们看着办啊，
他得恨你，
他会觉得你有200万，
你凭什么只给我20万啊？
你怎么那么贪心啊，
你怎么那么没良心啊，
你怎么都不念旧情啊，
他会恨你啊，
理解了吧，
但是关系也没有差到那种程度，
吃到头上来了，
完全做不到说一点都不崩，
说不了那个话，
好，
那你想问我啥问题吧，
怎么处理比较好？
我刚刚跟你说的，
你是一点没听进去啊。
跟进去了，
必须釜底抽薪，
你才有可能还有一份亲情在，
你不釜底抽薪的话，
到最后都很好，
因为我刚毕业一年多嘛，
也比较年轻，
自己也赚到了钱，
会想着出去玩啊，
但是他们看到这种消费，
他们都知道平时出去玩啥的，
就怕装不了，
你就不会说你出差吗？
你就不会说你出去谈项目吗？
你就不会说你出去学习培训吗？
你非得说你出去玩吗？
好，
为啥要发朋友圈呀，
为啥要让大家知道啊，
对，
有点虚荣心好的，
我知道了，
这样我也会慢慢去落实，
告诉他们我这个行业也不太行，
该不该还是会帮，
比如说他们买房这些出一点都完全不嘛，
他俩都已经是信用都已经烂包成那样了，
就像你说的话，
他俩就已经翻不了身了，
这种情况下，
坦率的说啊，
买了房子贷款谁还他们，
他们欠他们一屁股债，
亲戚朋友的债欠着他们有钱还呢？
我爷爷他退休工资可能每个月会给他们2000，
那你爷然后呢？
那就让他们别买，
本来就是欠那么多债，
信用都乱包了，
还惦记着买房子，
就跟那个电视剧里似的，
自己手上你分没有，
非得问大姑姐借100万买房子谁还呢？
到最后不还指着你吗？
你掺和他们干什么呢？
你妈愿意帮你妈有养老。
你妈有退休金，
你妈能从你爷爷那骗来的一点棺材本，
你妈愿意帮是你妈妈的事儿，
你爷爷愿意帮是你爷爷的事儿。
哼，
我爸妈他们都没有养老金，
还要靠我养老，
所以不到最后都算你头上了吗？
我跟你讲啊，
人真的很奇怪，
到最后还有都得恨你，
全都得恨你，
你为什么帮的不多一点？
你什么当初不帮我？
你明明这么有钱，
你一年都挣60万了，
你怎么就不能帮我还债呢？
怎么眼睁睁的看着我欠债呢？
都恨你好，
我知道了，
我还想问的就是，
因为我这个年纪在我们家小县城也到了适婚的年龄吗？
像我这样长得普通，
家里也没有助理，
甚至还拖累我，
你觉得我有必要考虑婚姻吗？
有必要啊，
而且我觉得你应该嫁的远一点，
既然你是做电商的，
去深圳去参加培训啊，
去那些电商环境好的地方，
广东啊，
去参加培训啊，
离得远一点啊，
我跟你讲啊，
你现在一年能挣60万，
你要是一年能挣160万的时候，
你说啊，
哥哥少了吃不上饭了啊，
这个孩子上学没有钱了，
我一个月帮你点可以吗？
不可以，
那你捐款不也得捐吗？
你捐给别人不也照样捐吗？
你抱着这样的心态，
你可以，
但是你不要离家太近，
离家远一点，
能挣钱的女人都给我，
我也是，
之前也想过，
我一个人去别的地方离家远一点啊，
不然你挣的钱都不是你的钱，
你一个未婚的女性，
你在原生家庭里头，
你挣的钱都不叫你的钱，
你必须离家离得远一点，
你挣的钱才叫你的。
钱你不要恋爱脑啊，
我不会，
完全不会，
家里都西巴玩成这样了，
我是做短视频那种带货零食食品这一块的，
我菲姐您觉得我还能怎么做？
能做的更好，
我也赚更多，
就可持续一点，
我好害怕，
就这两年能赚到几十万，
未来就赚不到了，
我还想多惨一点的。
有一个人你好好去学习一下，
叫胡楚静，
真的是互联网圣体，
他每一个时代都踩中了互联网的风口，
你多观察他，
多跟着他，
你看看他最近又干嘛呢？
又卖什么呢？
又怎么做流量呢？
跟着他学一学，
他也有一个账号是专门教做互联网的，
叫做自媒体的，
我觉得他讲的很多东西是非常有道理的啊，
叫胡楚静，
他叫电视机碎碎念，
知道的，
你跟着他学一学就是最后嘛，
我爸爸妈妈也50多岁了，
我妈妈就一直是家庭主妇，
爸爸现在是当保安，
两三块钱一个月的工资，
他身体不太好，
这个工作也不知道能做多久，
就看他身体，
两个人都是农村的，
没有社保，
好像农村在交什么养老保险吧，
你们也就每个月也就几百块钱，
今年我出了钱给他们交的，
爸爸不是身体不好嘛，
我也怕他一生病，
到时候我又白干了。
今年了解到的百万医疗保险就给我爸妈，
还有我三个人都报上了，
那您觉得在我爸妈啊，
养老保险还有这种医疗这方面，
我还有什么能做的吗？
他俩多大？
七二年的，
53，
我原来是想给我爸妈一次性交养老保险的。
呃，
特意打听过，
好像60岁之前是可以一次性买断的交养老保险，
将来他们每个月能领一点养老金，
你问一下你们当地的政策，
可能不同地方的政策还不一样，
都可以问一下，
其实我觉得这事儿是好事儿，
给你爸妈一次性把这个钱交了之后，
他们老有所依，
老了之后有一个尊严，
比如说每个月从你手上领个1500块钱，
和每个月从他自己的养老金账号里面领1000五块钱，
体验感是不一样的，
他总觉得每个月从养老金那里领1000块钱，
这是国家给他的保障，
他会有心里踏实，
你知道吧，
我都更应该也有期待给，
对，
就是你爸爸舍不得，
可能说啊，
一次性掏出个几万来给他们交上，
就这样啊，
好的，
谢下来，
记得点赞关注哦。